to other world news now and Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski says
Russian forces have destroyed the
eastern city of bakmut turning it into
what he described as burnt ruins
fighting has reportedly intensified
around the city in the Donetsk region
zelinski says the situation remains very
difficult in several Frontline cities
buckmort was home to 72 000 people it
became a main military Target for Moscow
in August it's the only major area of
the front line where Russian forces are
still trying to advance
for more on this let's bring in Rory
challenge who joins me live now from
Kiev hello there Rory what more can you
tell us about these latest developments
well the extraordinary thing about the
the fight for back moot at the moment is
that despite the fact that this city is
pretty much as we just heard there in
Ruins there are still civilians in the
town trying to eke out an existence
amongst the rubble uh living in
basements doing what they can to to to
to survive the the onslaught this fight
has been going on as you just said there
for months with the Russians seemingly
hell-bent on taking back Moot and
launching wave after wave recently at
least of full frontal assaults and it
has a lot of people scratching their
heads what trying to work out why do the
Russians want back moot so much it
doesn't seem to have much strategic
value now of course you can you can flip
that question and you can say well if it
doesn't have that much strategic value
why the ukrainians defending it so hard
it seems perhaps as if attrition is the
key that both sides the ukrainians and
the Russians are just trying to inflict
as many deaths as many casualties uh on
their enemies as they possibly can that
killing is the point grinding the enemy
down it really is hellish fighting I was
speaking to a soldier yesterday who was
here in Kiev uh to recover from a
concussion that he had received because
of an artillery shell that exploded
nearby he was just out of hospital and
he was saying that in the fighting
recently he'd been surviving on three
hours sleep a night for a week at a time
he'd had one ration pack for five days
of fighting on the front lines it's Grim
stuff there that is going on in back
moose now there of course there's other
fighting going on we have heard uh that
there were drone strikes launched by the
Russians yesterday at cities and targets
across the South of the country Odessa
particularly badly hit now there has
been some speculation about these
Iranian drones do they work well in cold
weather with some suggesting that
they're not equipped to fly in Sub-Zero
temperatures other suggesting that
because we've seen strikes recently they
must have been adapted by the Russians
to work better in Sub-Zero zones well
we've had a bit of clarification
recently from the uh from the Russian
sorry the Ukrainian Air Command saying
that because the temperature has been
above zero uh in the South recently
that's why we've seen more of these
Iranian drone strikes used by the
Russians the ukrainians have been
hitting back with drone strikes of their
own in Crimea overnight we don't quite
know the success of those yet we do know
of more success that the ukrainians have
had with likely High Mars strikes Now
High Mars is this Precision rocket
system that the Americans gave to the
ukrainians and other Western Partners
gave to the ukrainians and the Ukraine
has been using very successfully over
recent months it looks like they use
high mass to hit various targets and
occupy territory particularly topple
which is a southern occupied city with a
base a housing Russian troops there
burning overnight the ukrainians say as
many as 200 Russian Personnel were at
that base when it was struck all right
we really appreciate the update as
always Rory challenge live for us there
in Kiev
Yuri Sark is an advisor to the Ukrainian
Minister of Defense he explains why
Russian forces have been so persistent
in their advance
the reason why their attacks are so
Fierce and in many ways
um you know difficult to explain because
they have lost thousands of Russian
soldiers trying to take control of
bakmud now the main reason of course is
that in the second half of this year
the Russian army has not had any success
on the battlefield the last key that
they took control of was lift's chance
and since then it was only backwards for
them these attempts to encircle the city
uh were doomed and uh Russian army fled
from active region so uh it is indeed
trying to get a success for the sake of
success but the city does not have any
strategic uh importance
moreover what needs to be said is they
are using now in bakmud the same tactics
they've used before in cities like
mariupo like Ruby business so they are
raising it to the ground it's a barrage
of artillery fire day in day out they
are throwing their soldiers you know uh
both regular army the Wagner group the
so-called Wagner group the newly
mobilized they're dying there in
hundreds on a daily basis so it is very
difficult to comprehend what they're
trying to achieve they need badly some
success because otherwise they will meet
one year of this war without anything to
show their own people